if you see a reporter and they quote
they're quoting someone and they include
the
answers the likes and the um
to me that should be your radar should
be going up why am i including those now
does there are some reporters there are
very very few that do this that always
include the likes and hums no matter
what they will quote you directly what
you
said which i think is some form of
integrity but it's very difficult to do
because you're going to quote a lot of
people you're naturally not picking up
on the um's
so usually you take those out because
it's easier and
frankly it doesn't make the person look
bad um
so when they're included there's usually
an agenda
it's trying to make them look ditzy or
unsure or add to the new york times so
that's where like you take a quote out
of context include the and so like um
um i think you're driving it and then
you're like what are you talking about i
just i just wanted
to say what happened sure you did but
you had a part and so look
um yeah you wanna quote me there you're
gonna have my answer look
um like that's a thing that people say
and i'm fine if they do it every single
time
but i don't you just want consistency
you want equal treatment across all
people
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to yang speaks this is your
co-host zach grauman on today's episode
just when you thought we were done
talking about this mayor's race the new
york city board of elections threw a
curveball at us
uh it has disputed and corrected the
results so andrew and i talk a bit about
what is actually happening on the final
results of that race
and also the one and only carly riley is
backed by popular demand
we talk about this facebook case um
with the ftc we talk about the media's
new boogie man
and we even drop a little bit of free
britney in there which is not something
i'm particularly passionate about but i
did learn a lot
i think you guys will too because carly
is always dropping knowledge
so tune in right now andrew's here
carly's here right now on yang
speaks
[Music]
and we are back and uh i'm
here in in part to express my enthusiasm
for the fact that it looks like i
underestimated
the possible impact of ranked choice
voting on the new york city mayoral
primary
where catherine garcia may have a chance
to overtake
eric adams which as someone who endorsed
catherine heartily as my number two
choice and encouraged my supporters to
rank her second this would be a welcome
development there has been a lot of
confusion
about what is going on with the the vote
count
as of this moment so yesterday
the board of elections said hey we
screwed up we counted over a hundred
thousand dummy votes
in the count that we released which
is right i mean the the numbers did not
match up
i have to say this is very bad for
public confidence
that if you're going to share
information you'd hope that someone
would notice that the
numbers did not line up there was
another thing that i
thought and i believe that maya may have
made an announcement to this effect
which is that without the absentees you
don't know the precise order of
elimination
uh where it did not make much sense to
me that you would do
uh an elimination of the
lowest vote-getting candidates until you
had all the votes
um because it is possible that the order
of elimination changes based upon
who the absentees vote for um and so the
simulation may not
be helpful uh and so so those are two
things that are very very
frankly confusing um and uh
i don't think the boe uh would do it the
same way if they
they had a redo but i will say that it
looks like
the result is still very much in
question which is not what i thought
earlier but it looks like i was wrong
and i would be the first person to be
excited about about
being wrong in this context and this
could become a massive
celebration of the virtues of ranked
choice voting
i just hope the process holds up i'm
disappointed
that this is one of the this is probably
the biggest strength choice voting
election we've had and
we now have people questioning the
results so that's not great
um we need to get this right here's the
other thing i'm curious your thoughts on
this
this was where my head went it's like
okay we are the democratic party
we believe that
the free markets don't solve a whole
bunch of things that government is
needed to intervene at certain points
some a lot of democrats believe in
massive government right um
and government solving problems if we
can't count votes
how can we expect to sell the americans
that we can do health care
or uh smart regulations or
navigate ai that's you know like if
we're talking about lack of trust like
this is a blow
in my opinion i don't know i don't even
think of that um
you know we had this in iowa too you
know it was uh it's really deflating um
i don't know where your head is and if
it's a leadership thing it's a party
thing if it's just a lack of trust
uh just human error i don't know what
you think yeah i agree
zack uh it's a problem if we can't get
the process right and it's not like this
is the first time this has occurred
either for the boe
or even in your in my experience in iowa
where they had trouble
counting the votes if you can't project
confidence when it comes to
uh election outcomes it's very hard to
project confidence about a lot of other
more complicated tasks
so to me this should be something that
you take pains to get right and then if
you are going to deliver a public
statement you have to
be certain that uh it's going to build
confidence and not undermine it
yeah like if you screw up statement
number one's just screw up
statement number two better be right um
and that doesn't seem to be the case
the new york times had like a scathing
piece today on
i think they reserved us an older piece
about the problems of the board of
elections where people were just like
clocking in and leaving
not really doing any work and it's kind
of failed government bureaucracy
and i think to me was it just an epitome
of
um like a perfect crystallized example
of why you were running you're like i
don't think our leaders are going to
save
us and part of that is like they can't
even count the votes like there
um we need smart um thoughtful forward
thinking minds
nonpartisan minds frankly in in these
leadership positions because they affect
us
i want to build on the virtues here man
like i i did not think the rank choice
voting
um outcome could be this different from
the top line
based upon all the stuff that i'd seen
the previous simulations
the size of the gap the fact that voters
i'd talked to did not vote along
purely ideological lines but it looks
like
our endorsement our team up it looks
like my alliance with catherine
and my endorsement of her may actually
have made the difference
both in having her finish ahead of maya
as number two and then maybe even
finishing
ahead of eric as number one and if that
happens to me it would be the most
powerful demonstration of ranked choice
voting in action
uh i hope this comes to pass uh right
now if you
hold uh hold something up to me and ask
me like you know what do i think is
going to happen
uh it seems like it's about a 50
50 shot but being optimistic
now i i think that ranked choice voting
and catherine garcia are going to
prevail
um but that's you know that that's me
talking more about uh what i
hope will happen in many ways still very
exciting
uh and wanted to take this opportunity
to say
hey rank choice voting uh really could
end up being this
massive difference maker in this
election
and i hope this stands and i'm thrilled
that i might have been someone who helps
break ground in terms of
candidates cooperating with each other
that may even have changed the outcome
i agree that is the that is the silver
lining here um
and the rank choice voting stuff's fun
because the press doesn't know
particularly what to cover because a
front runner doesn't mean front runner
and
it's a good thing i think if you have
you know strong base of people all
around one candidate but the vast
majority of people don't want that
candidate someone like you can be like
hey the right thing to do is say like
this person and i you know we have our
differences but we'd be directionally
accurate so i'm going to put her as my
number two and that's what happened here
so i'm hoping
to that we get our you know what
together
and get these votes counted the right
way and that we trust the results
[Music]
all right back by popular
demand the wizard the oracle
carly riley welcome back to young speaks
thank you i feel like i've been back so
many times at this point that the intro
is the same every time it's starting to
get uh we're done
is that getting older you know you're
back but i appreciate it guess who's
back
back back back again okay
card he's back all right i'm done so we
got a few things to talk about
but i want to start with this one that
we were talking about before this
episode
i feel like the media's got a new boogie
man
or you feel like that and convince me
that
you were right and it's not you or me
you mean like we're not the boogeyman
yeah i was kind of joking because of
some twitter spats we had earlier this
week
new york times seemed like our last
episode y'all
coming at me on twitter we can get into
that too
but i do think um look we talked about
in the mayor's race
we talked about the presidential race
and i think we're talking about it now
is that the narratives
that our press drives and cnn is under
some heat right now because it seems
that their
newest narrative they're going to drive
is climate change it's not just cnn and
msmbc a lot of the mainstream events and
if you look
at the the two narratives that seem to
be coming through
in anything you're reading is both crime
and
i think now you're seeing climate change
around this uh
well this big heat wave and like who's
to blame or who's the wrong
side of this or what the book you mean
what are the bad things what are you
seeing here
talk to me i think you and i started
talking about this at one point because
some anchor at cnn or i don't even know
who it was but somebody said something
about
the fact that this miami housing or this
condo that collapsed in miami
collapsed because of climate change and
you had fox news
being like this is ridiculous you know
whatever i have no idea whether or not
that's true but what it would made me
think of
was the project veritas clips that were
released
i don't know a few months ago now people
may or may not know what i'm talking
about there
project veritas is like a right-wing
media watchdog
organization that does a lot of like
going undercover and secretly recording
democrats saying stupid things and then
they put it online
you know some of it i find quite stupid
and dishonorable
a few months ago project veritas this is
actually sad
we should also talk about why this is
sad project veritas one of their
employees some
whatever pretty woman matched with a cnn
employee on tinder
like intentionally ends up going on like
five dates with this dude
records them all gets this tech
employee at cnn to say all sorts of
things about how
cnn was clearly trying to get biden
elected how their
sole mission as an organization was to
make sure trump wasn't re-elected
so of course they put all these videos
online and conservatives go crazy and
they're like look see how biased cnn
is uh in any case you know fine okay
whatever
nobody is surprised frankly that cnn was
trying to get biden to win
these guys i'll preface this
conversation i don't have a problem
with and i don't think anyone should
really have a problem with like our
mainstream media driving
narratives and being businesses we've
set them up as for-profit companies
i don't like it but it's the game they
play we shouldn't expect anything
different they can say they want free
country
but we need to be aware of it which is
why we're talking with this i'm not like
faulting certain
you know other people can sure sure yeah
i look i don't
as much as i may on twitter sound like i
hate the media i have a
relationship because i would describe it
i love them when they say great things
about me and you
and yeah yeah and when the secret thing
is
okay no no but here's what i was gonna
say so as part of these
leaked project veritas videos in which
this insider at cnn said what he said
one of the things he noted was that
moving forward
climate change was going to become the
new boogeyman in the absence of trump in
a new era where you have democratic
leadership
and all of these sites need to have like
new things to go after to galvanize
their viewers
climate change was going to be the new
thing they were pushing over and over
and over again
on the network now look great i
obviously think climate change is very
real it's very much a problem
i'm not at all opposed to us pushing
this
narrative and trying to galvanize people
around it but i will say that
in in cnn's effort to attack this macro
problem
inevitably they are going to have news
coverage that on like the micro level
like an individual piece of coverage
may or may not be true may or may not be
reliable because they have a broader
agenda a broader narrative
around climate change that they're
trying to push again that's great but
like let's be discerning media
literate consumers and know that any one
given piece of information we're getting
about climate change or any one given
piece of information we're getting on
this
you know may or may not be the whole
challenge i think there's a good
argument that the last thing this
country needs is to politicize
climate change uh because it's gonna
affect us all
uh no matter what uh like
if the planet's warming up it's not the
hurricane doesn't care if you're a
republican or a democrat
yeah so that is is slightly terrifying
and i want to say like i don't
you know um one of the things we learned
and we've talked about it it's like not
just what the media covers
because i think a lot of them they get
sued when they're like factually
inaccurate
um they do have a lot of incentives for
them to
report facts but the problem is
it's both what you can say something
that's factually correct but not
necessarily be broadly with context
correct
it's not only what they cover what they
don't cover right of all the world
or things they keep pushing like lies by
omissions
yeah i mean look i i think i i'm
slightly more cynical maybe than you are
which is i think they actually lie with
impunity and the problem is that you
most people aren't gonna take the effort
to sue them and so
a lot of that is allowed to just go
ahead
uh like that's really what i've learned
in the last however many months is
how often people don't fight bad stories
because it takes a lot of work and
you went off on this that that then well
it went off carly went on a ramp we're
going to post a drink the back story
actually this is connected this is
connected to you getting
you know sort of some flack from the new
york times reporters i saw
a thread by a new york times reporter
talking about the last episode of yang
speaks
and i found her tweets on it just like
really obnoxious and and fit in this
like
fit perfectly into what i find
frustrating with the new york times
which is they say these things like
they're being neutral but there's
actually a whole side of the story that
they're not covering
and they are kind of snide about it so
this new york times reporter tweeted
something that
to my mind fell in that category and it
just like
brought this deluge of feelings
um yeah that came out in january 2021
beginnings mayor's race what would you
like to add carly i feel like you said
a lot of what you needed to say but for
those of you on twitter
yeah thoughts we can link to the thread
if people want to see
what i said i i i guess i would say two
things
um one i would say actually the list
that i
everything that i said on that twitter
thread is actually still not entirely
comprehensive i
i intentionally didn't defend you
specifically or the allegations against
you zack because we're dating and i've
tried to stay away from that
so as to not appear like i'm just like
seeking vengeance for my boyfriend
because this was so about so much more
than that for me and
um appreciate that but you know i so no
yeah of course so but so it's not this
wasn't comprehensive everything i said
that was wrong with this piece there was
there was more uh but the second thing i
would say that i had meant to put in
that thread but in the
in the heat of my tirade i i forgot was
the business insider editors that i
ended up being in contact with
after this story dropped were actually
very good to me
and were responsive and i think i don't
think it's that
these outlets want to be doing bad
journalism per se
it's a whole combination of factors that
lead to bad journalism
and then there's a lack of
accountability so that they don't
necessarily correct it
um and so i was really grateful for
those business insider editors and i
i felt a little bad because we had some
very nice email exchanges and i didn't
mean to
just wholesale throw everyone under the
bus um but it was egregious this article
was
just abominable and
to to know how much work went into
stopping it from spreading further
i i just saw why false narratives are
able to spread so easily because
it's so hard to stop them and it took a
lot of effort to stop them so for those
who did not
or not on twitter didn't see this carly
went off on twitter
on this business insider piece and look
i know you didn't want to
draw more attention to bad journalism um
during the mayor's race and
this piece was so bad yeah that in an
environment where everybody wanted to
write anything
they and everything they possibly could
on andrew yang literally every major
news outlet refused
to write this story but but it's worth
noting that they said that after we were
really proactive myself and other women
on
from the presidential campaign were
really proactive about saying hey
i know you're interested in this or
sniffing around this here's the full
story like we
we did a little bit have to spoon feed
that to people and then once it was
spoon fed to them they were like oh
they're like yesterday
but that's like team's job right you
show them like a good comment seems like
shows and facts and tells them
stop writing you know things aren't
factual uh on your
thread just to summarize you said uh one
problem with the
the piece was that there was one source
anonymous source made it seem like she
was ten people
um and she was actually a uh she said
she was a staffer when she was a
volunteer
um did not work for she was part-time um
there was someone that uh they implied a
very serious allegation of rape on the
campaign which was proven factually
incorrect those two people were dating
which is ridiculous
well and to be fair you can be raped
even if you're dating a person in this
case
it was not a rape and that woman was
happy to say yeah we were dating like it
wasn't like that um
he had both parties consenting on record
um or at least not background
they claim that you're a victim um to
like
toxic male culture with uh and left out
of strategic decisions which which
was unfair to you i mean they said that
you you all crafted a strategy that
essentially led to me being doxed on
4chan and i just knew nothing about it
i found that so infantilizing and like
and also at one point a friend of mine
pointed this out actually
somebody who knows me well in the
article they said
that i blamed myself for the doxxing
incident
um at some point or whatever and my
friend was like
do they [ __ ] know you like in what
universe would have you ever blame
yourself for that
like i don't know i was like that's so
true that that paints me is this like oh
like i
you know like i must have done something
wrong it's my fault like [ __ ] that this
was not my fault a bunch of imminent
[ __ ] on
4chan like our creeps and you know did
creepy things to me like that's their
problem you can read her thread we'll
post in the
in the description of this episode about
basically she just kind of eviscerates
this article which was very very bad and
very very incorrect they were
look we hired 300 people in about three
months like there were plenty of
uh like culture challenges in running an
outsider campaign and building that fast
like i'm not gonna say you're saying
this campaign was perfect but this piece
was garbage
and but my question is that's not really
the point the point is
um kind of where your time before is
narratives in the media
and i am on the point like i'm okay with
if a reporter wants to publish that crap
i don't like it i think it's stupid but
their peers should not be piling on and
continuing the same narrative they're
appear to be calling them out for
for like the the factual inaccuracies
but it's really
we're now learning that the peers like
the journalists are not doing this
themselves
so what would your advice be given that
type of piece we saw business cider
and stuff we've seen both the mayor's
race and the presidential race and just
press interactions in general
what can uh how if you're like listening
as podcasts
how do you identify when it's bs and how
do you identify
when it's real like how do you be
discerning as a reader
yeah i mean it depends on the kind of
piece
that you're reading right i think you
think you made this point zach
something that i didn't even get into in
my tweet thread was for this business
[Laughter]
something i i didn't even get into was
the way that this piece was written and
this is going to be
there'll be principles to take away from
this right was she frequently said
some former staffers said right and she
she used these
vague uh like identifiers or vague
adjectives like
some where it was clearly to hide the
fact that she had like two people
out of 250 saying something um
and i think really keeping an eye out
for
those kind of non-specific words
can be helpful if you're a media
consumer because it usually means that
the reporter's trying to juice their
story
like it's more accurate to give the
exact number
and if you have an interest in not
giving the exact number you probably
have an agenda if a reporter is not
using a number
if they're using words like some or many
or multiple
your radar should be going up because
yeah
let's think about it like after three is
a crowd essentially after three
four five six seven those those are big
enough to publish and if you're a
journalist you would publish that so
many usually means
either two or multiple or some usually
means two
or a small sampling for example when
a lot of people came after venture for
america and andrews worked there
and the employees there and what they
did they did dozens of interviews and
they got a whole bunch of positive
things to say
but what they had was a couple small
people say constructive criticism like
any organization would have
they quoted those that said some or
multiple sources said x
and that's when you should think
critically it's like uh
are they they interviewed a lot of
people there probably a lot of good
stuff that was said
does that feel accurately represented i
think the biggest thing
is we have a problem with scope in
the world right which is you could have
if the media is hyper focused on one
issue it makes that
issue seem like it's looming very very
large and it may or may not be
right like the number of incidences of x
can be made to seem like they're many
more than they actually are if the media
is hyper focused on the issue of x
so i think bearing that in mind just
just thinking like what is the
what is the denominator in any given
story or what is the denominator sort of
in a global
context of like is very helpful and if
you don't have that answer
then just take it with a grain of salt
let's say you're a boss
and you have you've had 100 people work
for you and
you had a great relationship with 98 of
them but you had to fire two
and now you didn't do it let's say you
didn't break the law you know physically
harm anybody nothing but you just had to
fight and they weren't good employees
if a reporter interviewed those two
people they could factually accurately
say this
multiple staffers had a severe issue
with zack rowman's leadership you could
say that statement yeah with carly
rallies
and that is factually correct because
there were two
and they did but it's also factually
correct to say the vast majority
did not the vast majority had a
wonderful experience
and it's like not a story hey a bunch of
people like were satisfied at their job
like no one won't say that so and those
people are not the ones going to
reporters like hey boy do i have a scoop
for you like
nothing happened i was treated with a
basic level of respect
like i did not leave the campaign and
run to a reporter to be like
boy don't you gotta cover the fact that
nothing bad happened to me at the hands
of my bosses yes
the vast majority of people had an
enjoyable experience working with angie
yang and bench for america and are proud
to have worked there and that
was always left off so that is something
um where i think where as we read as
readers
um to expect the media to autocorrect
there is
um a fool's errand in my opinion and
it's up to us to identify
you know like have your smell test
change a little bit well and
the biggest thing and i you know we've
now officially gone on a full tangent
here from our climate change initial
story but
i uh was just to see how the industry
that supports the media industry like
the ecosystem around that
whatever you want to call it consultants
etc etc have
sort of have seemingly come to just
accept this as being the way it
is like i was told by by professionals
in the industry
that this was fairly par for the course
and that you know basically don't worry
about this article it's
standard like kind of industry standard
and you know you people from the new
york times and politico retweet this
article
like and and i that was what was so
jarring to me was like oh wow we've all
just kind of like
laid down and died and been like yep
okay whatever walk all over me and
like that's just very anathema to the
way i'm wired yes that is true
um so that that was in some ways the
most interesting thing too was to
see that the other rule of thumb i have
for people reading articles if you see a
reporter and they quote
they're quoting someone and they include
the answers
the likes and the um to me
that should be your radar should be
going up why am i including those now
does there are some reporters there are
very very few that do this that always
include the likes and um no matter what
they will quote you directly what you
said which i think is some form of
integrity but it's very difficult to do
because you're going to quote a lot of
people you're naturally not picking up
on the ums
um so usually you take those out because
it's easier and
frankly it doesn't make the person look
bad
so when they're included there's usually
an agenda
it's trying to make them look ditzy or
unsure or active in the new york times
so that's where like you take a quote
out of context include the and so like
um
um i think you're driving it and then
you're like what are you talking about i
just said what happened
sure you did but you had a part and so
look um yeah
you wanna quote me there you're gonna
have my answer look um like that's a
thing
people say and i'm fine if they do it
every single time
but i don't you just want consistency
you want equal treatment across all
people those are my two guys when you
see
vague uh quantifying terms like many or
multiple
or some be careful when you see and
likes and um's and so's be careful as
well that's my
that's my two seconds there's too many
anonymous sources in one story
ask yourself if maybe some of them might
be the same person yeah i mean i mean
you've said this as well like anonymous
and you said you were upset about um
being an anonymous source is a really
powerful tool for
women because 100 percent power has been
said
it's a powerful tool for anyone who's
been exploited
or used and so when you use it
manipulatively as
when you use it as a way to juice your
story which is what happened in this
business insider case
you actually blunt that tool that very
critical tool
becomes weaker for every next person who
wants to use it honorably and i think
that's why stories like this undermine
the greater cause that really matters
which is
standing up for women in the workplace
and this article actually did a
detriment to that right
it wasn't furthering that cause so
anyways
okay so that's it so anyways cnn's gonna
talk a lot about climate change at least
not to take
is a new narrative the new boogeyman is
probably climate change uh we'll see
what happens
this is not my hot take this is the
project marital cnn person
okay saying this don't back down stick
to your guns carl i believe
fine you're into this we're putting you
on that yeah you've been you've been
correct so far
you called uh you called robin hood
you've called a few gift goats
gift goats doing great um we never
bought one because we're poor
i did i had people reached out i missed
it i apologized everyone who dm'd me
on instagram i think and said like hey
i'll lend you money to buy a gift goat
and i missed it i apologize
you didn't check your dms and people
lent you money what is wrong with you
they didn't they just said they would
they would oh my gosh
i give up
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is sponsored
by better help
i cannot recommend to you enough how
important mental health is
and how much i love better help i do a
secure conversation
with a counselor once a week
every time i talk to her feels like i'm
letting off steam and it's amazing and
it helps me prepare for the rest of the
week
helps me talk about the things that i
may be bottled up throughout the week
um where it's good to get it out and
it's so easy to use
it's fantastic guys it's time for you to
start taking control of your own mental
health
and stop letting things interfere with
your happiness
and you can start communicating in under
48 hours whether it's about depression
stress
anxiety relationships anger family
conflicts grief you name it
it's convenient affordable and
professional so start living a happier
life today as a listener of yank speaks
you're going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com so join over 1
million people have taken charge of
their mental health
again that's betterhelp hglp.com
yang
[Music]
the ftc is suing facebook um attempting
to break them up
um and uh under the leadership
of who's someone who seems to be a true
badass um or at least aligned with a lot
of i think lina khan who's the um
have you read about this one she's the
new ftc chair she's 32. she's 32.
like come on like you're embarrassing
that's amazing she's a badass
yeah she wrote a paper in 2017 called
amazon's
anti-trust paradox paper went viral in
these influential circles
let's call it like it went law school
viral i guess um
and she argued that the dominance of the
text titans like amazon show that the us
anti-trust
laws are broken um because they're
focused on
consumer pricing instead of basically
like
competition um and so the argument
is like well what do we care it's not a
monopoly if consumers are paying less
money
and their argument is that well that's a
dated view of monopoly
so basically the ftc has been filing a
bunch of anti-trust lawsuits against a
number of big tech companies
the news this week is that a judge
basically
didn't so didn't last the ftc out of the
courtroom but was like dismissed the
case before it even
got its day in court and that was
shocking like that
that was not what people were expecting
and and the judge gave
the ftc basically 30 days if i'm not
going to save it
like to improve their case and come back
with an improved case before
it's able to move forward i the media
has not
said this so i'm going to say it this
was lena's first
shot like some of the things the judge
is saying
judge james bossberg that's kind of a
cool name
he said a couple things one you
concluded that facebook you being the
fcc concluded that facebook has a market
share of 60
but back that up with no data no obvious
reasoning so
that feels like a rookie i don't know
enough about loss i don't know but that
feels like a
no no look look up for me right now when
when was lena
appointed to the ftc chair i believe it
was in the last like month like yeah
that exists in this case at present
pre-date okay so not me
but still like she's gotta know it's
this is i think
wrong stuff so and so the the thing is
now is like her first real big move
honestly as to ftc chair
is going to be spending the next 30 days
fixing this working
to strengthen this case like she's now
inherited this problem
and i think the real measure of her and
it's a tall order so i don't necessarily
think we should write her off even if
she doesn't do it she doesn't if it
doesn't work but
the real measure of her is going to be
over the next 30 days
when they come back to the judge the big
hurdle they're fighting though is like
that
facebook bought instagram in 2012 and
whatsapp in 2014
and those were both reviewed by um
anti-dress court at the time and they
found no problem
and then so the quest the judge was like
why why did you wait so long if you
really
now ten years later you're bringing an
issue and that's not his fault um
that is a number of reasons um so i'm
curious your thoughts on
angie talks with us a lot he thinks um
you know they're not a traditional
monopoly
but they are uh they're selling our data
we get the product free and they sell
our data and a lot of people don't know
that they don't know the depths of it
there's so many different sides of this
um but thoughts on your thoughts on this
in general carl and then
where do you think this goes where do we
think we land well
the angle that i always
that i feel like has been missing when
i've the little bit that i've kind of
read and dug into this has always been
the okay
what does breaking these companies up
mean for consumers
right like for you and me why do i care
about this what does it mean for me
and like what are the pros of doing this
and and you talked about david
data privacy i think i don't understand
how separating instagram and whatsapp
from facebook
does anything for my data privacy it
doesn't so that's andrew's point
yeah so so i i think that's so i'm like
okay
what good he's always said that what
good does it do if you make another
google maps and a bunch of like
five smaller googles doesn't make google
doesn't like increase competition per se
maybe a little well but but
is that the argument is that more
competition will mean
more people trying to woo consumers and
one of the ways they may try to woo us
is by having better data privacy
settings like maybe that's the
roundabout argument but frankly most
people don't actually give that much of
a [ __ ] about
data privacy like they're like i got
nothing to hide fine take my data like
so i don't see that playing out i think
the other the other argument i guess
as i've kind of dug into this is like
all right it increases competition for
small businesses for smaller players
that's great i i don't understand how
breaking up again instagram and facebook
does that just set the precedent that
facebook couldn't buy up its competition
in the future like
i don't really understand how breaking
those up necessarily protects smaller
businesses um so this is the piece that
i've always been confused on is
great in theory i guess i'm for breaking
up big tech but i don't actually really
understand how it helps me
or well the thing is all the data
is owned by facebook right or these
three or four companies and the problem
is if you want to
market in the 21st century you have to
use facebook and that's like the
that's what you're trying to avoid right
that's what you're trying no you have to
use facebook king
um and so we had a we had a conversation
on
e-commerce and we talked about if you're
a like it's it's amazing for these young
companies to come on like you can hyper
target and
not have to carry inventory because you
know exactly who's buying in real time
but at the same time you have to use
facebook and is that good or bad
for okay but that's because all of the
users are there
no of course and that's where consumers
are and that's not changing if you
separate instagram and facebook like
none of this is i guess my point is that
like i don't understand breaking up is
not breaking up sounds good
it's not going to solve at all sure and
and you know i'm intrigued by this idea
which i think
you got into or lena talks about this
and and other people in the wake of this
court decision have been saying this
we really need to update our anti-trust
laws
to better reflect and
encapsulate sort of the internet age and
and maybe that would be what we need to
solve these things that i'm talking
about but
otherwise i sort of feel like this feels
like an you know an elite
legal battle and i don't really care in
the sense that like i don't
really know what's in it for me if my
data is still just going to be sold
ad nauseum and facebook's still going to
have 10 trillion users and
the other you know it's fun for me
carl's like the the cons let's just take
like the conservative argument here
where it's like this is bipartisan it's
a lobby but there is a certain element
was like hey
i'm conservative i'm pro-business and
like if you're a country on a global
scale you want your cash cows to kick
butt
and then you tax them and you tax your
billionaires
and people make billions off it um and
that's good for
government programs like you want cash
cows to fund your government
that all like i don't necessarily agree
with that argument but i i see the logic
until
until you start to see what just
happened and pro publica did a bombshell
report that said
like we've known that the facebook's
amazons don't pay any taxes so the
company itself is not paying
[ __ ] tax and the billionaires aren't
paying taxes
that's ridiculous though i will say here
here's the there's like this like secret
republican in me and i'm a big fan of
like
you know let's tax these people tough
vermont liberals secret republican tell
me more about her
carly well just more that like you know
and jack dorsey is not like broadly
representative but like
he donated a third of his wealth like a
billion dollars this year towards like
covid prevention or coveted research or
whatever the heck uh
women's education and ubi and i was like
women's education and ubi are basically
the two things that i think are going to
like
save the world women's education i think
that included like contraception like
there's so much research on how
contraception
is a game changer no country has lifted
itself out of
uh poverty in the last 50 years without
expanding access to contraception to
women
so so somebody like jack dorsey for me
it was like that billion dollars was
better off in his hands than in
the government's hands where it gets
siphoned off to like 10 trillion
different
you know little at least yeah
right yeah of course and that's that's
just anecdotal and in general
billionaires don't give nearly enough
away
someone who's worked a lot of
philanthropists uh
that's true you were that was your game
no idea what the hell they're doing not
that the government does either but you
know like it's
like
at least theoretically checks and
bounces theoretically i
um i will say the last thing on this
unless you have other
super hot takes that you want to share i
i do get a kick out of a bipartisan
element of this
because it's this fun thing where you
have democrats just in general are in
favor of antitrust and government
regulation
and conservatives just hate big tech
they just like hate jack dorsey and they
like
they're like we're being censored it's
liberal yeah and so like
we have this funny like you know come
together for very different reasons
without some surprises this is one thing
everybody kind of agrees on like yeah
you're kind of too big
like there's a problem here i know and
maybe it speaks to the weakness of the
government's case that of course hasn't
been able to happen
of course um so this will be
you know like zuckerberg has done things
that objectively
whether you're really loose you want to
evolve your definition of anti-trust
laws or stick with the conservative ones
things where he has been quoted in the
email i think it was
two thousand i'm gonna look this right
up it was uh
i don't know i remember when he actually
i don't know the date sorry but he said
an email it's better
to buy than compete um in 2013 there was
a
social media company called circle that
was growing um
and they were competing a competing
social network and
when they couldn't buy it they just cut
off access to its data and systems
because that's how they were getting a
number
of uh of new users and such and so they
stopped we went from gaining six hundred
thousand new users a day
to zero um and that's like what facebook
that's a problem
and that to me is a question of i i
guess this anti-trust regulation like
breaking up instagram and facebook
prevents that i'm just not clear enough
i suppose on whether or not
retroactively making changes to the
structure of facebook
prevents future actions by facebook um
to to suppress competition presumably
yes in which case great and i'm in favor
i'm not an expert maybe she's an
anti-trust law i'm curious of what
um i'd be fascinated to learn what was
happening
during like the rockefeller age where
you had
um oh yeah you know like what and like
it was more of the wild west can i give
a fun rockefeller story
go for it okay this is from ap us
history i learned this
um so john rockefeller at like the
height of his
you know fortune success like richest
dude in the world
was taking a tour of one of his like oil
factories and they were putting the oil
in the barrels
and he asked them how many drops of glue
they used to seal the barrels of oil
and they told him and he was like all
right like try it with like with
one fewer and one fewer and basically
was like to to save costs was like
how few drops of glue can we use to
successfully seal these these barrels of
oil and it was just
like 16 year old me was like that's what
it takes to be successful like that
level of just detail and like
god how will i ever like compete with
something that that like you have all
the money in the world and you're still
like
how many drops of glue i want to save
that not even half a cent
you know meanwhile you probably got some
like poor like factory oil rig worker
who's got like rich ass john rockefeller
breathing down his neck being like this
[ __ ] first he said five drops
now it's
the heck four uh fascinating to watch
my prediction on this and i'd love your
thought i think they either we're gonna
f it up
like government's not getting it done or
they're gonna get something done that
like facebook just kind of skirts around
like something stupid like you have to
break up your companies but they still
kind of owe them
like well an interesting take i heard is
that big tech is basically going to
start
funneling money to the conservatives and
into conservative members of congress
because again their
their horse in this race is basically
like we don't like big tech
so the the argument i was hearing was
like if they just give enough money to
republicans
they'll kind of back off and wind up
with some watered-down version that
really doesn't do anything
who knows but i think that's an
interesting take and probably not
not impossible by any means i want to
talk about this it's um
people are very upset right now
particularly republicans so the olympic
trials are happening so the u.s olympic
camera threenberry um
protested the national anthem but in a a
way it hadn't been done before i think
there's been times when
and obviously like famous instances
where people have raised a fist and
kneeling for the anthem not of the
olympics is obviously a very powerful
thing and it was um
i'm you and i are both on record like
being very supportive of colin
kaepernick and that
movement in this instance she put a
shirt over her head
and like turned her back on the flap she
turned it back on the flag and um
yeah i have no problem with this at all
i find it to be
honestly shocking that we're even having
this conversation again
i felt like we'd come to this agreement
as a country that like
colin kaepernick kneeling was actually
not a big deal because
hey you know like then there was looting
and writing and all these things and it
was like well we tried to kneel and he
didn't listen so now we're getting
looting and rioting so the fact that
like now somebody's turning their back
once again a non-violent action and we
have to like debate like
is this right like the big question is
like
how do you want black people to protest
right like how do you want them to
express
their frustration she has a platform
like forget what you think the not you
specifically but the generic you
think about the state of racism in this
country clearly she feels
very strongly about it she has a
platform she's choosing to protest in a
non-violent way
great like it's it's it's just so
strange to me that we're once again
making something like this a thing
after we saw that there were really in
my opinion like
there are much worse ways that we could
protest and make this point i agree with
that i think everybody else
make your statement the reason i was
like a little more because i would never
really had the
this influence but it was what made it
feel different this time was that's the
olympics like you're
it is it's two things i think globally
and i think it's unanimously globally
one it's a time where all the countries
put aside their differences
and compete it's always been a symbol of
harmony and peace and representing your
national pride and you choose to go
represent your country like it's not
like you're a football player you play
for the 49ers you're like i make me do
this i think
there's problems you choose to go play
football for a private business and
you're not representing united states
you're barely representing the team you
play on because they trade you so so
often
but you are choosing to represent the
united states of america and you
when someone and you go then like but
i'm you know i'm going to look at the
flag
feels i understand the reasons
are are very just but it's still you
live here
you're a gifted athlete you live here
you're a gifted athlete
this is your passion the two things can
exist at once which is
you want to be able to compete at the
highest levels at the sport that you
love
right and you can feel really not
prideful
in your country right and and people can
be mad that she's not proud of her
country
but to me she has every right to express
it this way like she's not hurting
anybody
i just i i fully see where she's coming
from with it and i have no problem with
it and i think
it's one of these stupid i think the
fight is even stupid like i just find
everything about it
meaningless symbolic
let her do what she wants she's drawing
attention to this issue
you know for people you and me who spend
our time
on the left and listening to the left
like we're very aware of this issue and
so it can feel like
okay we all already know about this but
half the country doesn't know about this
or like hasn't accepted this problem yet
now do i think her turning her back on
the flag
makes them see this problem no i think
it makes sense i think it's more
divisive
in their own anger yeah fine but like i
don't want to disagree that you're like
she's not hurting anybody like i do
think it's divisive
um who is she hurting i don't know the
little kid that's like why
mommy why am i saying like why don't we
like the flag here no
great and then you no of course not then
great that's a great conversation hey
honey she's really frustrated because
there's some people who feel like this
country doesn't look out for them the
way they look out for it looks out for
other people
like you start that conversation with
your little kid and it's not harmful
it's
you know it's doing exactly what she
intends for it to do which is to start a
dialogue
not a war that's not the point of the
olympics was my my point
it's a really rare opportunity to show
that we're one nation after all of our
differences but
um but she doesn't feel that way she
feels that we're
we have two different americas for if
you're black and if you're white so i
think that's the thing you're trying to
suggest
and that's where you can you may
disagree with her philosophy right like
but but then you know then this is a
conversation about whether or not like
how bad racism is which
we don't want to have i think you and i
both very much believe that it exists
obviously it's a huge problem so like
you know you don't want to go down that
that that's been a different rabbit hole
like whether or not it's bad enough to
warrant this
right and and that's fundamentally what
republicans are saying is oh it's not
bad enough to warrant this right
right um
yeah totally and and i and and then it's
just like where do you draw the line
problem i i haven't followed the
coverage
by republicans on this because i do not
care i know what they're going to say
um yeah i but
i would be curious to see the comparison
of like how they covered the
you know january 6 capital insurrection
and this like
i could very much see like them being
given kind of equivalent coverages
as if these are in any way commensurate
and it's like it's that stuff that just
makes it feel so ridiculous i agree
okay she turned her back like she made a
symbolic gesture about a problem she
sees like i just
i don't care fair enough totally support
her right to do that last thing for that
you go carl
britney spears oh i you stole my thunder
i i thought you were going to say
something else
and i was going to have to be the one to
bring up britain i did it you brought
i'm not following this
do you know anything i know this britney
spears was my
first love she has had
a roller coaster of uh what's called a
relationship with the media yeah this is
bringing it full circle i mean this is
another
story about media narratives there's
nothing the media loves more than
building up
like a beautiful young woman so they can
like document her
or create her fall uh it's just the most
like it's the oldest
media trick in the book is just the way
they treat women it's a really
fascinating window into an element of
our system that we
rarely get to see this whole
conservatorship system do you know you
have to tell us what happened
okay okay so essentially for the last i
don't know decade plus
britney spears has been in a
conservatorship after her breakdown in
call it i don't know 2008 or whatever
she shaved her head
she attacked a paparazzi car um
her dad basically took control of her
entire life
her finances who can visit her where she
can go
birth control like everything about her
life is controlled currently by her
father and has been for over a decade
now
um this is like unprecedented as far as
i
have seen um usually conservatorships
are for people who are in their
you know their elderly and they
physically cannot take care of
themselves anymore
she was under the conservatorship during
her last like
worldwide tour like after she released
the circus album she was touring
internationally making
millions upon millions of dollars and
wasn't allowed
to make a decision about being on birth
control or you know who got to come
visit her so
um and and for a long time there's been
this like grass roots free britney
movement
that have that have like been sort of
seen sometimes as a conspiracy theorist
that she's like
sending them secret message through her
instagram posts and she's secretly
miserable and it's
it's always not been clear if they're
right or not because she hasn't been
she hasn't spoken publicly really about
the conservatorship um
but she finally spoke out last week last
week i guess
um and to a judge um saying that
the conservatorship is abusive saying
that she's been forced to work seven
days a week for the last
decade basically she has no control over
her own life she wants to have another
child she wants to marry her current
boyfriend she's not allowed to because
the conservatorship she has an iud in
that they won't let her take out wow
um she had to she and her boyfriend just
went to maui on vacation she said that
um there were certain like work
agreements that she had to meet
before her father would let her go to
maui
like just crazy things for a 40 year old
woman
who's a total superstar so no you know
the the total prevailing narrative right
now is like this is clearly ridiculous
britney spears should not be in a
conservatorship
um this is abusive and there's been some
things made of like
this is this should give people insights
into the way that people with
disabilities are treated in general and
that we shouldn't just take this to just
be a problem for brittany that there's a
lot of people with disabilities who are
treated
very poorly and actually have should
have a lot more autonomy in their lives
that's part of the conversation i will
say again being the media or being the
skeptic in general about narratives that
i
am because the entire narrative is that
i am curious what the rationale has been
for the last decade
by judges to say that she's needed a
conservator um
you know that's true we haven't had the
other side clearly there is we don't
know
all of what she's struggling with what
her mental health conditions are she
clearly has a bit of a mental health
struggle so
you know i don't wanna again i'm never
going to just totally bandwagon
something
um one argument listen to us and i'll
say one argument was that
she was at risk of losing her kids back
in 2008 she was going to lose custody of
her kids and so that
she voluntarily because she did
voluntarily enter into this
conservatorship
as a way to keep her kids and then once
you're in a conservatorship it's
actually very hard to get out of it and
the legal structures in place are very
much set up so that
conservatives can't often get out of
this easily um
so it could be that with the situation
she in in a moment of desperation wanted
to make sure she could keep her kids
entered into this and then has been
stuck in this like legal gridlock
i don't know uh but i i think it's
actually just fascinating i think it's
fascinating on a whole bunch of levels
i'm a pop culture junkie so i love it
from that
standpoint the depth of issues we're
talking about with you carl
always fascinating what what's your call
are they going to let her
out i it seems like
yes um she has to file a petition to
be released from this conservatorship i
think that hasn't quite happened yet but
she
just made a move to retain new legal
counsel
um and the just national attention
around this
seems to be reaching a feverish enough
pitch that it seems like there'll be a
there'll be a change that'll come thank
you for that update carly
riley always a pleasure to have you uh
we'll do it again soon thank you for
joining yang speaks girl
thank you all right talk to y'all soon
[Music]
you